Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner development team. Today I'm going to talk a little bit about
Incy Wincy mode in Burp Scanner. So we're continually adding features to Burp Scanner
so that it can increase coverage when crawling the modern web, especially when there are behaviors
that make crawling otherwise difficult. But some web applications are actually really easy to crawl,
and we don't necessarily want all of these bells and whistles turned on if they come at their cost
of performance. So how does Incy Wincy mode differ from the default crawling settings? There are three
main ways I'm going to go over using Portsfugger's Gin and Juice Shop to do some manual examples.
So the first way in which they differ is path walking. By default when Burp Crawler is running,
what it'll do is if it's on a page it will record all the links it sees as well as where it's seen
them and then walk back to where it saw each link before following it. This means that it makes sure
that it's always got the same session as when it saw a link to make sure it'll be there when it goes
back again. So if we have this page for example, the products page in Gin and Juice, it's got all
these product links. What it would do is effectively put the Gin and Juice Shop address in the address bar
and go to the products page and click on product one and put the Gin and Juice Shop address in the
address bar again, go to products, go to product two and so on and so forth. How Incy Wincy mode differs is
instead of maintaining a list of paths, it just maintains a list of URLs that it scraped off the
page. So again, if it was on this product page and it saw all of these product links, what it would do
is just record the URLs and paste them into the address bar directly. So it would first go to product
one and then it would put product two in the address bar and product three and so on. This is pretty much
exactly how Burp Spidey used to work and is where unsurprisingly the name Incy Wincy comes from.
The second way in which it differs is the use of Burp Suites built-in cookie jar. So because by
default the crawler is trying to create and maintain sessions itself, it doesn't interact with Burp's
cookie jar at all. Incy Wincy mode on the other hand does. When it starts up, it'll take a copy of
all the cookies in the cookie jar and use those as a starting point for crawling. This is useful if you
want to use Burp Suites embedded proxy to authenticate and then have the crawler continue to use your
authentication, assuming it's cookie based. So for example, you could use Burp's proxy to go and log in
and then go and kick off a crawl using Incy Wincy mode and it would just continue crawling using this
this session. The caveat here is that again similar to the Burp Spidey of old, you have to make sure to put
any session killing links out of scope because Incy Wincy mode will, for example, see this logout link,
follow it and then just barrel on without noticing that it's lost its authenticated session.
Authentication is also the third way in which
the Incy Wincy mode differs from the default crawl settings, this time with automatic authentication.
So the way in which the default crawler handles authentication is in separate phases. Firstly,
the crawler will do one phase completely unauthenticated, making a note of any login forms
it finds along the way. It'll then do a follow-up pass where it goes back to these login forms and
uses any credentials you've given it to log in and crawl from there. So it would crawl like this
without any authentication, spot this login form and then in the follow-up pass it would go and fill that
out and crawl from there. The behavior is the same with recorded logins in that it'll do one pass without
any recorded logins you've given it and then it'll do a follow-up with those recorded logins and kind
of compare what it sees to what it saw when it was unauthenticated. Incy Wincy on the other hand does it
all in one go. So if you've given it any recorded logins it will just start with those or do them very
early on in the crawl and if it spots any login forms along the way it'll just fill them out as it
sees them rather than waiting to do them in a follow-up pass. So finally I'll hop over to Burp
Suite and just show you how to turn this on. So if we go to a custom crawl configuration and go to the
crawl optimization, Incy Wincy mode is actually on by default if you select the fastest crawl settings.
That's because we intended the fastest settings to work on or be used on the same kind of websites we
think Incy Wincy mode will work best on. So ones that don't use too many modern or difficult to crawl
behaviors. If you want to combine Incy Wincy mode with your own custom configuration you can manually
enable it or disable it inside these settings here. We added Incy Wincy mode or specifically the ability
to crawl favoring speed over thoroughness as a result of users asking for it. So if you have any more
ideas keep them coming.